I'll go first.
You first.
All right.
Oh, this is a sad one.
It's gonna take a lot of,
uh, a lot of weed.
I know, man.
I'm gonna be emotionally torn
after this one.
Yeah.
This is our first one,
too, man.
I know, I know.
Super emotional.
Like, when you watch a sad,
you know, dying-dog movie,
do you, uh,
cry every time?
Absolutely.
Not every --
I didn't --
Well, yeah,
I guess...
Is "Air Bud" sad?
Yeah.
"All Dogs
Go To Heaven."
"All Dogs Go To Heaven."
Remember that movie?
No.
Yeah,
that was a sad one.
It's about
a [bleep] dead dog.
It's like
the title tells you.
It's dogs in heaven,
you guys.
We got to keep our eye
on this poor doggy.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, God.
Because the doggy
is really, uh...
He's so cool.
He's the true victim
in all of this, I think.
Wait.
Do you guys think that's
a legit way to solve this thing?
See who
the dog likes?
Absolutely.
That's justice.
That's how they used to do it
back in the, uh, 17th century.
Yeah.
Well, what about the --
What does the law say?
'Cause I know you guys
went to law school.
Well, it's her property,
so, like, it's hers.
Right.
Those are her rights.
But, uh, she doesn't seem
to care about the dog.
Right?
So what do you do
as a judge?
You ignore...
Hmm.
You ignore the law?
It'd be interesting to see
who the dog goes to.
Yeah, see,
I feel like --
And do we have them both
go "Come here, come here,"
or do we have them
just stand there?
No, I think you --
No, no.
I think they shouldn't
say anything.
I think you got
to keep it objective.
It feels like
the guy's gonna win
if we let
the dog decide.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Maybe best out of three.
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughs ]
Best out of three works.
Yeah.